this is listen I don't know that I
needed to do this but we have now a
beautiful
significant statistically significant
double-blind
placebo-controlled trial of that little
old drug the anti-parasitic drug called
ivermectin for covid now I know it's
been a while and so some people maybe
say David where where is what did you
just pull this out of your ear no
four months and months and months
the indifferent to the science right
wing
was aggressively promoting something
called Ivermectin to treat covet they
would promote it prophylactically they
would promote it as an acute treatment
for covid there were people like the
candidate for Arizona governor Kerry
Lake who claimed she was just taking it
prophylactically to prevent coven and my
position was
listen test everything
test spinach
test niacin test diver test whatever but
let's have double-blind
placebo-controlled randomized controlled
trials so we can accurately say these
things do work for covet or they don't
it would be great if we found something
cheap and widely available like apples
or Ivermectin that was good for covid
but unless we know that it works it's
irresponsible to claim that it does and
the right winger said you're suppressing
this and you're blocking that and you
don't want they they don't want the
truth to be known and the more and more
and more data that came out the more we
believed it didn't really work we now
have a very good study and indeed the
sugar pills worked better now I want to
be clear the headline is kind of a joke
right the headline is Ivermectin worse
than sugar pills the sugar pills are a
placebo and what you have is almost
identical effects between people
actually getting Ivermectin and people
getting the sugar pill so the headline's
kind of a joke but the truth is the
Ivermectin doesn't work study released
three days ago effects of ivermectin
versus placebo on time to sustain
recovery in outpatients with mild to
moderate covid-19 a randomized clinical
trial okay the key elements here the
question they were asking folks this is
a science right this is what this is how
we figure things out question does
Ivermectin daily for three days
compared with Placebo shorten symptom
duration among adult patients over 30
years of age in the United States with
symptomatic mild to moderate covet 19.
that's the question now you can always
come in and say they didn't dose it
correctly they should have tested five
days they should have tested it only on
severe covid or only on mild or
impatience of 25 years okay every test
is only testing something that's this is
what this test is trying to figure out
and the findings determined that
Ivermectin should not be used in
outpatients with mild to moderate covid
because it didn't do anything
okay when you look at design setting and
participants this is this is how we
folks this is how we figure out stuff
um this was a decentralized
double-blind
randomized placebo-controlled trial
okay decentralized means it wasn't all
done at one location it wasn't okay
we're doing a test at this one Hospital
everybody who's part of the test has to
be right here no it wasn't done that way
it was double-blind meaning neither the
patience nor the treating individuals
the medical professionals knew who gets
the sugar pills and who gets the
Ivermectin it was randomized meaning
that there was not a selection of okay
let's see u3 go in this group and then
u4 go in the placebo group because that
can then uh be affected by the bias of
the experimenters who might consciously
or subconsciously say let's let's like
put the healthier people in the
Ivermectin group because they're more
likely to do well no it was it was
randomized and placebo-controlled
meaning some people got
fake drug but they didn't know okay it
was designed to evaluate repurposed
therapies meaning drugs that already
exist but are being explored for
treating covid in outpatients with mild
to moderate covet okay
1591 patients 30 plus with covid with at
least two symptoms and an acute
infection less than seven days old
meaning they were started on the trial
before seven days of covet had gone by
okay very good uh participants were
randomized to get Ivermectin or a
placebo
the um okay results these are this is
the the most important stuff here okay
the most important things the median
time to recovery was 12 days for the
Ivermectin group and 13 days for the
placebo group now you might say well
look the Ivermectin group recovered one
day quicker uh that difference of 12
versus 13 days is not significant enough
to prove Ivermectin is more effective
than doing nothing the difference in the
number of people being helped by
Ivermectin and the placebo is so small
that there is not evidence that these
that one day difference is anything
other than just chance
um it's essentially the same and in fact
it's really a range the median time to
recovery was 11 to 13 days for the
Ivermectin group and 12 to 14 in the
placebo placebo group now importantly
what about more serious outcomes well
there were 10 hospitalizations or deaths
in the Ivermectin group and nine in the
placebo group there were fewer deaths in
the placebo group and fewer
hospitalizations and deaths
um again not statistically significant
so the joke is the fewer people died
with the sugar pills the it's not a
statistically significant difference now
let's say what would be significant in a
group of sixteen hundred people with
covet right imagine that only 10 of the
people getting Ivermectin ended up in
the hospital but 200 of the people
getting the placebo ended up in the
hospital then we would say whoa that
seems very unlikely to be by Chance the
Ivermectin maybe was doing something
so the uh very clean very very good
study now some of you might be saying
why did we get that early data that
Ivermectin maybe worked for covid the
best explanation we have for that right
now
is that Ivermectin is an anti-parasitic
drug
some of the early populations at whom
they threw Ivermectin were in countries
with a higher prevalence of parasitic
infections in humans the Ivermectin
treated the parasites and overall people
do better generally speaking when they
don't have parasites so
that would be the explanation of why the
Ivermectin may have shown a false signal
at being effective for covid um in some
very small early tests all right we have
the data we can put it to bed except
Carey Lake still talks about how great
Ivermectin is quick break right back
after this